>>female Announcer: I'd like to
welcome back the pop master,
Matt Hales,
also known as Aqualung.
This is his second performance at Google
and I hear this CD is the best ever.
He does a fair job of performing on his own
so without much further ado
please welcome Aqualung.
[audience applause]
>>Aqualung: Thank you.
This is very early.
[Aqualung begins playing notes on piano]
I'm going to do a special karaoke
version of the songs,
especially early in the morning.
[Aqualung begins playing
"Good Times Gonna Come"]
♪ I need to know if you're letting go.
♪ It's alright, it's alright,
it's alright.
I didn't know I was hurting you so.
It's alright,
it's alright,
it's alright.
You came to me from nowhere,
with nothing,
and no one.
Hold tight,
hold tight,
hold tight.
It goes to show you never really know.
It's alright,
it's alright,
it's alright.
This is just one of those lonely nights.
The good times gonna come.
♪ [piano playing]
See me then investing so much.
In you,
in you,
in you.
I came so close to the edge.
I do,
I do.
This is just one of those lonely night.
The good times gonna come.
In the end,
we let it go away.
We let it float away on the breeze yeah.
'Round the bend,
the sun is in the sky.
It's starting,
it's gonna be,
yeah,
it's gonna be a bright beautiful day.
Oooooh,
oooh,
oooh.
This is just one of those lonely night.
The good times gonna come,
♪ [piano playing]
the good time gonna come.
Need to know if you're letting go.
It's alright,
it's alright.
It's alright.
♪ [piano playing]
[applause]
Thank you.
I feel like I should be teaching you something.
Maybe I am teaching you what is possible
to do with a human voice
after one hour of sleep,
but I've always been-
like I was a choir boy
and in some ways my voice
has kind of stayed the same
so I really like it when,
you know, your environment provides an
[inaudible] because you get to sound rugged
because I don't think I can pull it off
so I am enjoying
my karaoke self this morning.
It's a bit more like Tom Waits
who did an excellent Jones.
♪ [Aqualung begins playing
"Something to Believe In"]
♪ You talk too much.
♪ Maybe that's your way
of breaking up the silence,
♪ that fills you up.
♪ But it doesn't sound the same,
♪ when no one's really listening.
♪ We stumble into our lives.
♪ Reach for a hand to hold.
♪ Any wonder we need to find
a certain something, certain.
♪ Turn out the light
and what are you left with?
♪ Open up my hands and find out
they're empty.
♪ Ooh, press my face to the ground
I've gotta find a reason.
♪ Still scratching around
for something to believe in,
♪ something to believe in.
♪ You have too much.
♪ You're spending all your time
collecting and discovering,
♪ it's not enough.
♪ And no matter how you try,
♪ you never find the one you want.
♪ We stumble into our lives.
♪ Reach for a hand to hold.
♪ Any wonder we need to find
a certain something, certain.
♪ Turn out the light
and what are you left with?
♪ Open up my hands and find out they're empty.
♪ Ooh, press my face to the ground,
I've gotta find a reason.
♪ Still scratching around
for something to believe in,
♪ something to believe in.
♪ Ohhh, ohhh, ohhh.
♪ Ahhh, ahhh, ahhh,
♪ I just need something to believe in.
♪ Come on, come on,
♪ come on, come on,
♪ come on, come on.
♪ [piano playing]
[audience applaus]
Something's gonna change
their meanings according to contents.
It seems to me one little dot
in front of everything else.
In the evenings,
this song I'm about to play seems like
it's the story of unrequited love
and keep you romantic.
At this time of day,
it's a little bit more like,
perhaps, a serial killer song
[audience laughter]
so you choose.
[Aqualung begins playing
"Strange & Beautiful"]
♪ I've been watching your world from afar,
♪ I've been trying to be where you are,
♪ and I've been secretly falling apart,
unseen.
♪ To me, you're strange
and you're beautiful.
♪ You'd be so perfect with me
but you just can't see.
♪ You turn every head
but you don't see me.
♪ I'll put a spell on you.
♪ You'll fall asleep
and I'll put a spell on you.
♪ And when I wake you,
I'll be the first thing you see,
♪ and you'll realize that you love me.
♪ Yeah,
♪ [piano playing]
♪ Yeah.
♪ Sometimes,
♪ the last thing you want comes in first.
♪ the first thing you want never comes,
♪ and I know,
♪ the waiting is all you can do.
♪ Sometimes,
♪ I'll put a spell on you.
♪ You'll fall asleep.
I'll put a spell on you,
♪ and when I wake you,
I'll be the first thing you see,
♪ and you'll realize that you love,
you love me.
♪ I'll put a spell on you.
♪ You'll fall asleep
and I'll put a spell on you.
♪ But when I wake you,
I'll be the first thing you see,
♪ and you'll realize that you love me, yeah.
♪ Yeah,
♪ [piano playing]
♪ yeah,
♪ yeah.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ Ohhh-ooh,
♪ ohhh.
♪ Oooh,
♪ oooh.
♪ I'll put a spell on you.
♪ [piano playing]
[applause]
This is Aaron by the way.
He says hi.
[audience laughter]
I'm kind of bringing you in,
in a way.
What we're going to do,
to warn you,
is we've got like a kind of squad.
It's like 'sport'.
It's like 'sport' but a squad of pro athletes
slouching on the red couch over there
and one by one they are going to come out
until this stage is full of fine musicians
making an unholy racket.
You're probably gonna want
to dance around and go nuts.
In the event that anyone doesn't
want to dance around and go nuts,
we're just going to say that's fine.
You can just go nuts inside,
which is how we prefer to do it in England.
[audience laughter]
It's much more seemly.
So we are going to try this and we've
never tried this one before and it's new.
This features the magic of
two Aarons with only one Aaron.
It's magic.
Not quite magic just yet.
Here we go.
It's magic,
it's magic here.
♪ [Aqualung begins playing
"Remember Us"]
♪ Baby don't talk.
♪ Don't say anything.
♪ No need to say anything.
♪ 'Cause lately when we talk,
♪ we just spin around.
♪ So tonight,
♪ why don't we just sit down?
♪ Let our shadows show us what to do,
♪ what to be.
♪ And in the hush,
♪ remember us.
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh-oh.
♪ Skin across my skin.
♪ Do you feel a thing, darling?
♪ [piano playing]
♪ Will you know me now?
♪ In this remembering,
♪ remembering how we used to be.
♪ Oh, not how we're supposed to be.
♪ And in this room,
♪ we come undone and we find
there's a soul and mind,
♪ they intertwine and we find,
♪ and in the hush of memor- oooh, oooh,
♪ oh oh oooh.
♪ Oooh, ooh, ooh, ooh,
♪ [piano playing]
♪ Oooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, yeah.
♪ Oooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
♪ In memor-
♪ darling I,
♪ [piano playing]
♪ darling I.
[applause]
That was pretty good, Aaron.
So this is Mark.
He's going to, he's setting up.
♪ [Aqualung begins playing notes
on the piano]
Some of these are songs
from the new album
which is called "Magnetic North".
You have appeared to already have received it.
I don't know they decided
to call me a pop master.
It makes me sound like - you know,
I don't know what that makes me sound
but the worse thing is if people
would think that I'd maybe asked,
like Michael Jackson, and say he has
to be referred to as the King of Pop.
Well, you know, contractually, you need
to refer to me as the pop master,
but that's not what I think.
I like just to be doing this.
I can't do nothing advanced.
♪ [Aqualung begins playing notes
on the piano]
[silence]
This is called "Lost."
♪ [Aqualung begins playing "Lost"]
♪ Daylight comes in the nick of time.
♪ Shines some light into
the darkest corners of her mind.
♪ All the world is,
♪ all the world is weighing down on you.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ Oooh, ohh, ohh.
♪ Ahhh, ohhh, ohh.
♪ Piece by piece,
♪ it all falls away.
♪ All this beauty, all this magic
'til there's nothing there.
♪ If only love was enough,
♪ I would reach you,
♪ I could reach you.
♪ I know I'm not tired
but maybe you got tired of me.
♪ It seems like every little thing
I do makes you pull yourself away.
♪ So I'm waiting for the sun,
♪ but you only see the grey.
♪ Oh no, oh no, oh no,
♪ oh no-
♪ won't you please come on home?
♪ Oh, oh.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ Ooh, oh, oh.
♪ Oh, I've been missing you,
♪ you got lost along the way.
♪ Oh maybe you aren't lost;
it's still in you some way.
♪ If only love was enough,
♪ I would reach you,
♪ I could reach you.
♪ I know I'm not tired of you,
♪ but maybe you got tired of me.
♪ It seems like every little thing I do
makes you pull yourself away.
♪ So I'm waiting for the sun,
♪ but you only see the grey.
♪ Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no-
♪ won't you please come on home?
♪ Oh, oh, oooh.
♪ Pull yourself away.
♪ So I'm waiting for the sun,
♪ but you only see the grey.
♪ Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no-
♪ won't you please come on home?
♪ Ohh, oh, oh,
♪ [piano playing]
♪ yeah, yeah.
♪ If only love was enough,
♪ I would reach you,
♪ I could reach you.
♪ [piano playing]
[applause]
Thank you.
So next to the party is an excellent,
wonderful artist from Australia
who's been back on tour with me playing
and opening up and being part of the band.
So please give a muted lunchtime
welcome to Krista Polvere.
[audience applause and cheers]
>>Krista Polvere: Hello.
>> Aqualung: That was my last piece
of energy I just used up
That woo.
I'm going to sleep now.
>>Krista Polvere: Okay, good night.
On this one, I'm going to sing one of
my songs and it's called "See You At Last"
and continue to play some of Matt's songs.
♪ [band begins playing "See You At Last"]
♪ Left alone like a lingering whisper,
♪ disappear in the glimmer of his eyes.
♪ Fading thoughts in this old hotel,
♪ where their hopes seem broken
in the wires.
♪ Empty windows,
♪ painted glass,
♪ overgrown,
♪ oh that's not you.
♪ What we lack of charm is that here
I've held you in my arms.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Headed over to the bells in the steeple,
♪ rusted out and overplayed.
♪ Holding on was a flame on his candle,
♪ flickering strong.
♪ They say lights and turn on.
♪ I'm afraid.
♪ Overblown, we are safe.
♪ Two hearts lost in the seas
without anchors.
♪ It was here I held you in my arms.
♪ [guitar and piano playing]
♪ Empty rooms,
♪ painted glass,
♪ overgrown,
♪ oh that last you.
♪ What we lack of charm is that here
I held you in my arms.
♪ [guitar and piano playing]
♪ Held you in my arms,
♪ held you in my arms,
♪ [guitar and piano playing]
♪ held you in my arms.
[audience applause]
>>Krista Polvere: Thank you.
>>Aqualung : Thanks Krista.
>>Krista Polvere: Thank you, Matt.
>>Aqualung: No, thank you.
Here we got stuck in a courtesy loop.
It happens a lot; it doesn't happen
in the UK because we're just rude
but here you can really get-
I moved to California six months ago .
and it's taken me a while
to get used to things
I got stuck in a restaurant
for about half an hour.
It was like - the guy came up and said
"Do you want some water?"
And I said, "Thanks very much."
And he said, "You're welcome",
and I said, "No, thank you."
And he's like, "No."
I was like totally frightened.
It was like great, thanks a lot
for the water- no, you-no, you got it...
yeah, it's fine...
and it went on like that
for the half hour I was stuck there.
I had two meals.
Just what you were looking out for,
it's just a little life tip.
I think actually looking at the time
and bearing in my mind everything
that we have to bear in my mind
that we should probably go I think direct
to "Fingertip" and then we have be there.
Sorry, Steve.
[inaudible]
There's work to be done,
so we're going to finish with this one.
The two golden rules in Aqualand
is you write the songs;
it's gotta be slow, sad,
have no hand claps,
and absolutely no doo-doo's
but I broke all my rules with this song.
What was I thinking?
♪ [Aqualung plays a few notes
on the piano]
So thanks for coming to listen
and thank you for all that you do
and I guess I'll see you downstairs
in a minute.
You can ask me questions
and I will try to answer them.
This is called "Fingertip".
♪ Doo doo, doo doo, doo doo do.
♪ I wanna knock knock down your door.
♪ Wanna steal your bicycle.
♪ Wanna rock your rocking horse.
♪ Wonder what's the time now, Mr. Wolf.
♪ Dancing in the street.
♪ With my suit and my big white teeth.
♪ And my shirt and my big white shoes.
♪ And almost nothing left to lose.
♪ In a minute, I mean it,
♪ you lose your grip.
♪ 'Cause you're hanging, by a fingertip.
♪ I'm gonna huff you and puff you
and shake your tree.
♪ Gonna make you,
♪ fall in love with me, yeah.
♪ Oh oh oh,
♪ Ooh ooh ooh.
♪ This is the beat , beat,
beat of my heart.
♪ It overheats every time we're apart.
♪ With the sweat dripping off my chin.
♪ Honey you don't know the shape I'm in.
♪ Oh, struck down in the street.
♪ Staring up, up at the swings of your feet.
♪ Nobody knows the way that it is.
♪ Come on baby, baby please.
♪ A minute, you lose your grip.
♪ 'Cause you're hanging, by a fingertip.
♪ I wanna huff you and puff you
and shake your tree.
♪ Gonna make you,
♪ fall in love with me.
♪ I want to eat with you, sleep with you,
kiss you and listen to you.
♪ Get you what you want,
♪ give you what you need.
♪I want to sing to and cling to
and wait and see.
♪ Gonna make you fall in love with me.
♪ Ooh,
♪ ooh.
♪ 'Cause they don't know.
♪ They don't know.
♪ In a minute, a minute,
you'll fall for me.
♪ In a minute, any minute,
wait and see.
♪ In a minute, I mean it,
you'll fall for me.
♪ In a minute, any minute,
now wait and see.
♪ Doo doo, doo doo, doo do.
♪ 'Cause I've been waiting,
impatient, down underneath,
♪ just to catch you when you fall for me.
♪ And in a minute, I mean it,
you lose your grip.
♪ 'Cause you're only hanging on
by a fingertip.
♪ I'm gonna huff you and puff you
and shake your tree.
♪ Gonna make you,
fall in love with me.
♪ fall in love with me.
♪ Gonna make you make you
fall in love with me.
♪ Yeah.
♪ [piano playing]
This is where you'd do a jump.
Do a jump, Krista.
Thank you.
[audience applause]
Good afternoon.